the Lusitania America's ship effete it's May 1st
1915 Germany is at war with France in England and
has warned the United States but if the Lusitania
sales team might be torpedoes despite the Teutonic
edict the shipment is to fling us into World
War one is jammed as it leaves New York Harbor
as passengers lined the rail they are getting
their last look at land and at lights no hint of
the panic that is to come six days later here no
suggestion of trepidation no feeling of disaster
but then off the coast of Ireland the first German
torpedo struck Germany's flagrant violation of
international law first belowdecks the warning
had its tragic aftermath Germany was inviting
us to war as wreckage of the Lusitania is
pounded by the surf off the Irish coast
public indignation arose in America Woodrow Wilson
attempted to mediate between the warring nations
but the Lusitania remained in the hearts
of Americans and these survivors thought
the Lusitania avenged for America fought to make
the world safer democracy and the
sea safe for peaceful travelers